talvez alguns de vocês estejam bem
surpresos de ver a mãe sofreu por aqui
na verdade eu confesso que até o mesmo
estou muito surpresa mas também muito
grata pela oportunidade mas podem ficar
tranquilos que nós não vamos começar
nenhuma aula de catequese agora tá bom
na verdade venha conversar com vocês
sobre pessoas que têm os cabelos cor de
prata pessoas cheias de histórias de
marcas e de memórias pessoas por onde o
tempo passou e se materializou quando a
alemanha invadiu a polônia
os soldados chegaram em nossa casa no
final da tarde
nós tínhamos que deixar tudo para trás
subir nas carroças e - meu pai a quem
eles mataram com tiro ali na minha
frente
simplesmente porque ele trabalhava na
construção civil e poderia vir a
questionar o modo como as construções
eram feitas no campo de concentração
fomos todas levadas para trabalhar na
fábrica e na fábrica
tudo que a gente faziam era coisas pra
guerra armamento munição fardamento
essas coisas a gente trabalhava muito e
não podia parar porque se a gente
parasse eles batiam na gente e além de
trabalhar muito durante todo o dia
no final do dia a gente tinha que ir pra
casa dos soldados colher batatas e
cuidar dos animais
eu sentia que as minhas roupas estavam
ficando pequenas mas na verdade era eu
que estava crescendo com os meus agora
14 anos não tinha nem muito que comer
nem o que vestir
e muito menos perspectiva de como seria
o futuro quando a gente estava na
fábrica gente ouvir os aviões voando
baixinho e o barulho das bombas caindo
então a gente tinha que correr para os
abrigos se proteger e só quando as
sirenes desligavam e o barulho diminuir
a gente voltava do trabalho na fábrica
quando a guerra acabou
nós não podíamos voltar a polônia porque
a polônia que antes estava invadida pela
alemanha agora eram os russos que
estavam lá e nós não podíamos voltar
então ouvimos falar que tinham navios
partindo para o brasil e as pessoas
falavam que o governo brasileiro estava
dando terras para todas as pessoas que
chegassem para recomeçar a vida
então nós viemos para o brasil sem saber
falar uma palavra em português
essa história continua e eu tive a
oportunidade de escutar la por inteiro
da própria pessoa que viveu tudo isso
onde vocês imaginam que eu tive essa
oportunidade pois bem foi em uma casa
para idosos
todos nós aqui sabemos que o
envelhecimento é um boom dos nossos dias
podemos dizer que o envelhecimento é uma
questão tão conhecida quanto ignorada
conhecida porque falada nos jornais nas
revistas na mídia na internet e não só
porque falada porque mediada mas também
porque está comprovado pelas
estatísticas
segundo o ibge a população de idosos no
brasil até 2060 não vai simplesmente
duplicar pasmem a população de idosos no
brasil até 2060 vai quadruplicar
por outro lado
podemos dizer que o envelhecimento
também é uma questão ignorada porque é
como se os idosos fossem um público
invisível das políticas públicas para os
padrões de investimentos sociais
jurídicos inclusive privados mas porque
isso porque é um assunto que conhecemos
tanto deixamos tão de lado e por que
essa capa de invisibilidade sobre os
idosos porque os idosos precisam estar
tão associados a essas duas rodas porque
o interesse pelo público idoso é tão
pequeno e é interessante a gente
perguntar sobre isso porque dentro de
algumas décadas talvez bem poucas e que
passam bem rápido
nós mesmos vamos fazer parte desse grupo
aliás nós já fazemos parte dessas
estatísticas
e se a gente fala sobre uma capa de
invisibilidade sobre os idosos em geral
que dirá a grossura dessa capa
quando a gente pensa sobre os idosos que
estão nas casas de idosos bem aqui em
blumenau existem 11 casas como estas
quantos de vocês alguma vez já estiveram
em uma casa como em uma casa dessas
talvez poucos podia ser muito mais mas
porque a gente não vai a irmã porque sei
lá né uma casa só pra gente velha uma
casa assim a gente idosa eu não sei nem
como é que eu ia me portar não sei como
é que ia puxar conversa eu acho que eu
me sentia deslocado gente talvez o
problema não seja existir casas onde só
moram pessoas idosas pessoas velhas
velho mesmo é o nosso preconceito com
relação a essas pessoas a esse público
ea essas casas e por causa
da imagem de precariedade que acompanhou
essas casas ao longo de várias décadas
a gente sempre pensa em fazer alguma
coisa pois bem já que estamos aqui todos
motivados pela proposta do pedex de
quebrar paradigmas
eu gostaria de convidar a todos vocês a
dar um pequeno grande passo nessa
direção
vamos quebrar esse paradigma quando a
gente pensa em casas de idosos
assim no senso comum mesmo com a
primeira imagem que vem à mente um local
sujo de abandono precário as coisas
caindo aos pedaços no local quem sabe
até de maus tratos ea gente até às vezes
fica sensibilizado com isso ea gente
pensava em fazer alguma coisa vamos
arrecadar alimentos e leva lá vamos
arrecadar fralda geriátrica e leva lá
vamos arrecadar material de higiene
pessoal e leva lá porque afinal de
contas eles são idosos e eles precisam
dessas coisas
não está errado tá certo eles precisam
dessas coisas mas nem só de pão vive o
homem
parece que na relação entre comunidades
locais sociedade e casos de idosos
a relação é sempre de fora pra dentro
onde a comunidade se reúne e vai lá
deixar coisas pra suprir as necessidades
materiais dos idosos porque esse
movimento também não pode ser de fora
pra dentro pra levar lá coisas para
suprir as necessidades subjetivas dos
idosos como companhia interação
entretenimento cultura lazer e tantos
tantos outros
e por que esse movimento também não pode
ser de dentro pra fora onde os idosos
saem
das casas de idosos para idosos ou
instituições de longa permanência para
idosos como a nomenclatura correta no
brasil e ocupam os espaços da nossa
cidade
os idosos nas praças os idosos nos
parques os idosos nos shoppings os
idosos nos cinemas os idosos nas praças
de alimentação e vem das vitrines
tudo bem aí é real que infelizmente
muitas instituições ainda têm em sua
realidade essa imaginário que a gente
falou no começo de precariedade
mas gente será que precisa ser sempre
assim
não definitivamente não não precisa ser
assim e o que a gente pode fazer para
que não seja assim
existe muitas respostas para essa
questão
mais uma delas talvez esteja na própria
proposta do tet blumenau fazer conexões
lembra daquela história que eu contei lá
no começo pois bem as casas de idosos
estão transbordando de histórias
vamos até lá vamos até eles
os idosos são como livros vivos e que
fala olha que tecnologia maravilhosa e
eles podem nos contar sobre qual seja o
nosso tema de interesse moda política
futebol cultura costumes das décadas
passadas
eles podem nos contar sobretudo porque
eles vieram antes de nós
eles construíram a eles construíram a
nossa cidade
eles abriram as estradas que nós depois
asfaltamos eles cultivaram a base do
braço e da enxada os campos que nós
depois reviramos com os tratores
eles ergueram os prédios que abrigam os
nossos escritórios eles
pegam nas mãos nas rugas e no coração um
arsenal gigante de histórias e de
memórias histórias e memórias que se nós
não ouvi los
se nós não registramos de alguma forma
com a chegar com o passar do tempo e com
a chegada das demências
todas essas histórias vão se perder e o
que a gente pode fazer para que isso não
aconteça fazer conexões ea gente pode
fazer essas conexões e tocar pelo menos
essa história para que ela seja
diferente através de ferramentas que não
estão muito próximas
os próprios nossos hobbies e talentos
coisas que a gente já gosta de fazer
já faz com muita tranquilidade e que não
exige tanto de nós sabe aquele violão
empoeirado lá no fundo do seu armário
que tal pegar esse violão e lá pra cá
pra eles a irmã mas eu não terminei o
curso eu não sei fazer todas as notas já
faz um monte de tempo que eu não toco o
meu violão com as cordas afinadas e daí
se você deixar de fazer um boa nota no
meio da música eu te garanto ninguém vai
perceber porque o que importa não é a
nota que você fez o que deixou de fazer
importa que você foi até lá você sentou
se ao lado de uma pessoa idosa
você cantou para ela e com a sua canção
você abre uma janela da memória e das
histórias que ela pode te contar tudo
bem se não tem aptidão para a música mas
gosta de fazer fotografia
que tal fazer uma exposição só com
personagens de idosos o que você gosta
de fazer o que você tem prazer em fazer
e que pode oferecer prazer a vida de uma
pessoa idosa bem porque a gente tem essa
idéia sobre os idosos e que talvez seja
o que nos dificulta a aproximação
de que os idosos são uma gente que está
em declínio porque os idosos precisam
está tão associados a essas rodas e ao
invés disso eles não podem estar
associados a estas rodas
afinal são duas rodas igual
muda apenas o contexto eo olhar gente
envelhecer é verbo que nos perpassa mais
cedo ou mais tarde seremos nós a
conjugalidade e em causa própria porque
vamos perceber que o tempo bateu em
nossa porta entrou em nossa sala sentou
se ao nosso lado e passou seus braços
sobre nossos ombros
espero que até lá já tenhamos a
tranqüilidade de saber quem cuidará de
nós as pessoas que chamamos de família
às comunidades às quais fazemos parte
o estado que rege a nossa conduta social
pis a todos eles juntos
não vim para a aula de catequese mas se
possa terminar com uma irmã
peço a deus e desejo a todos vida longa
muito obrigada